It's time to dust off the
fedora and crack the whip one
more time! As our favorite globetrotting
archaeologist returns to the big screen,
here's everything you need to know about
Indiana Jones and the Dial of Destiny.
The last time we saw Indiana Jones, he was
exploring the jungles of South America,
avoiding killer ants, and hanging out with
a greaser sidekick played by Shia LaBeouf.
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull hit theaters all the
way back in 2008, and it was actually the second
highest-grossing film of that year worldwide, but
it's not exactly beloved by hardcore Indy fans.
So the stakes are pretty high for Dial of Destiny,
which is set to land in theaters a little
over 15 years after the last adventure. It
was originally supposed to be released in
July 2019, but two additional release date
changes and one pandemic later, it's finally
scheduled to hit theaters on June 30, 2023.
Indiana Jones has faced his fair share of
bad guys over the years. In Crystal Skull,
he was up against a group
of Soviets in South America,
and he narrowly avoided having a heart to
heart with a cult leader in Temple of Doom.
But there's one particular group of baddies
who cross Indy's path again and again: Nazis.
As it turns out, Indy's not done with the Third
Reich just yet, as he'll be butting heads with
some sinister Nazi faithful in The Dial of
Destiny. According to an exclusive report
from Empire Magazine, the film will be set in
1969 during the height of the Space Race. In
both the film and in real life, the American
government employed multiple Nazi scientists
to beat the Russians to the moon. In Dial of
Destiny, one of them is the nefarious Voller,
whose loyalty to Hitler's regime remains strong.
According to Mads Mikkelsen, who plays Voller,
"He's a man who would like to correct some of
the mistakes of the past. There is something
that could make the world a much better place to
live in. He would love to get his hands on it."
We're assuming that that something is the Dial of
Destiny, which Indy will need to find first with
the help of his goddaughter Helena. The story
will also focus on Indy truly growing old and
getting ready to take off his fedora for good. As
writer-director James Mangold explained to Empire,
"It became really important to me to figure out
how to make this a movie about a hero at sunset."
We'll also get some clarification on what's going
on with Shia LaBeouf's Mutt Williams.
While the actor won't appear in the film,
Mangold told Entertainment Weekly that
we'll indeed learn what happened to him.
You simply can't think of Harrison Ford
without also thinking of Indiana Jones,
and vice versa. And Ford seems to genuinely love
playing Indy. So even though he's 80 years old,
he'll be stepping onto screens for
one more go-round as Dr. Jones.
"I'd always wanted to see Indiana
Jones at the end of his career,
towards the end of his life, when
everything catches up to him."
John Rhys-Davies will also be returning to
play Indy's best friend Sallah. Outside of
this franchise, Rhys-Davies is probably
best known as the ax-wielding dwarf Gimli
in the Lord of the Rings. Indy will also
be teaming up with a new character in the
form of his goddaughter Helena, whom James
Mangold described to Empire as "slippery,
charming, the girl next door" and "a grifter."
She'll be played by Phoebe Waller-Bridge,
who's best known as the creator
and star of the sitcom Fleabag.
As for the big bad, it'll be Mads Mikkelsen as
Nazi scientist Voller, who's tricked the U.S.
government into thinking he's abandoned his
old ways. Mikkelsen is no stranger to playing
antagonists, as he's delivered villainous turns
in the likes of Casino Royale, Fantastic Beasts:
The Secrets of Dumbledore, Doctor Strange,
and as the title cannibal on NBC's Hannibal.
Voller's murderous enforcer Klaber will be played
by Boyd Holbrook, another actor who specializes
in scary roles, like Commander Donald Pierce
in Logan and the Corinthian in The Sandman.
In addition to those big names, Antonio Banderas
is set to show up in a cameo role. Plus,
Toby Jones will play Helena's dad Basil.
The cast will be rounded out by Shaunette
Renée Wilson, Thomas Kretschmann,
and bodybuilder Olivier Richters.
When you think of the behind-the-scenes
talent of Indiana Jones, obviously Steven
Spielberg springs to mind. The celebrated
filmmaker directed the first four Indy films,
and it's almost impossible to imagine the
franchise moving on without him. However,
Dial of Destiny won't see Spielberg calling the
shots. While he will remain on hand as a producer,
he stepped away from the director's chair so
that a younger filmmaker could take the reins.
That leaves The Dial of Destiny in the very
capable hands of James Mangold, who should be
a great fit. The story is supposedly about an
aging Indy going on one last adventure before
riding off into the sunset, and Mangold has some
promising experience in that area. He co-wrote and
directed 2017's Logan, which is the acclaimed swan
song to 20th Century Fox's version of Wolverine.
"Look. I gotta go."
In addition to Logan, Mangold's credits
include the Western 3:10 to Yuma, the
crime drama Cop Land, the Johnny Cash biopic Walk
the Line, and the sports drama Ford v Ferrari.
When it comes to film composers, there's
none more famous than John Williams. Jaws,
Jurassic Park, Star Wars, E.T., Harry
Potter, and Superman are just a sampling
of his iconic pieces. He even came
up with the theme for the Olympics.
Williams is also responsible for the rousing
scores that accompany Indiana Jones on each of
his adventures. And he'll be back for Dial
of Destiny, providing music that's sure to
get the blood pumping as Indy traverses the globe
once again. Interestingly, at one point in time,
Williams implied that The Fabelmans and
Dial of Destiny would be his last projects
before retiring. However, in January 2023, he
walked those statements back, as he explained,
"I'll stick around for a while. I can't retire
from music. A day without music is a mistake."
The teaser for Indiana Jones and the
Dial of Destiny dropped in December 2022
and promised all sorts of adventures for
our aging hero. When the preview starts,
it seems that Indy has been living
the quiet life of a college professor,
as an exchange between him and Sallah
makes clear. His old friend laments
that he misses waking up in anticipation of the
exciting adventures promised by each new day.
"Those days have come and gone."
"Perhaps. Perhaps not."
But while Dr. Jones may be done with adventure,
adventure isn't quite done with Dr. Jones. As
the teaser progresses, we see Indy picking up
his whip, getting in a showdown atop a train,
and exploring ruins filled with Greek
statues. He also makes his way through
a Nazi castle and an exciting chase at
a ticker-tape parade for the Apollo 11
astronauts. The whole time, he regales us
with his unique worldview, as he declares,
"I don't believe in magic, but a few times in my
life, I've seen things, things I can't explain."
"And I've come to believe it's not so much what
you believe, it's how hard you believe it."
In April 2023, we were finally treated to the full
official trailer, which is scored to the classic
Rolling Stones song "Sympathy for the Devil." That
tune makes it clear that Indy is a man outside of
time in the strange world of the 1960s. Speaking
of time, it's possible that that theme might play
a big part in the film, as Voller explains why
he wants to get his hands on the Dial of Destiny.
"Hitler made mistakes, and with
this, I will correct them all."
Could time travel somehow factor into all of this?
Is that why so many people want the Dial? Not only
are the Nazis after it, not only is Indy trying
to get it, but it also looks like Helena has an
agenda of her own, as she too is trying to get
her hands on this precious artifact. This prompts
a three-way chase across the world, complete
with undersea exploration and aerial action,
all in the pursuit of something that could
very well change the course of history.
Harrison Ford is obviously a Hollywood legend,
but he's also still just a mortal who ages like
everyone else. He's 80 years old, and
he presumably can't run around beating
up Nazis forever. Plenty of us thought that
he would hang up the fedora for good after
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull. But here
he goes again, in what surely must be
the final adventure. In an interview with
Total Film in April 2023, Ford revealed,
"This is the final film in the series,
and this is the last time I'll play the
character. I anticipate that it will be
the last time that he appears in a film."
"For me, this is it."
"Harrison, let me tell you something. You've
told me that two Indiana Joneses ago."
Granted, that claim may be a little naive
on Ford's part. If Hollywood can find a
way to reboot this franchise or start
a prequel series, they will. However,
we do believe Ford when he says that this
is the last time he'll play Indy. And if it
sounds like we're crying, that's just the dust
from all those ancient artifacts in our eyes.
De-aging technology is a great tool, but
its uses in film thus far have been a bit
wonky. The Irishman, for example, is a
fantastic movie, with a terrific Robert
De Niro performance. But those scenes with
him as a younger man just look plain weird.
However, it sounds like Dial of Destiny is
taking de-aging technology to the next level.
While most of the movie will be set during the
late 60s, the opening act will take place during
World War II. This segment will reportedly run
for 25 minutes, which means that James Mangold
must have plenty of faith in the de-aging
tech if we're going to be looking at an
artificially youthful Harrison Ford for nearly
half an hour. As Mangold gushed to Total Film,
"It was an incredible technology
[...] The goal was to give the
audience a full-bodied taste
of what they missed so much."
From the clips we've seen of the opening sequence,
Ford looks pretty fantastic, and better even than
recent examples of de-aging like Sean Young in
Blade Runner 2049 or Kurt Russell in Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 2. Evidently,
the jump from the 40s to the 60s is going to be
key to the story in Dial of Destiny. The film
will be hopping from an era when it was clear
who the bad guys were to a much more complicated
time. As Mangold told The Hollywood Reporter,
"It's not just a movie about a hero in
his twilight years who is called back into
action. It's more than just that his bones
might ache, it's that his soul might ache,
or that some of his optimism or sense [of]
fitting into the world might have evaporated."
Furthermore, Indy will be dealing with a body
that's much older and creakier than before.
Slugging bad guys in the face isn't going to be
as easy as it once was, with Mangold explaining,
"It reminds the audience of the contrast between
a hero in his physical prime and a hero at 70.
We're not relying solely on the audience's
memory of the previous films. It reminds
everyone what he's done, what he's survived,
what he's accomplished. By showing him in his
most hearty and then finding him at 70 in New
York City, it produces for the audience a kind
of wonderful whiplash of how they're going to have
to readjust and retool their brains for this guy."
"He's about to retire."
"Yes."
"From being a professor."
"And all hell breaks loose."
"It does."
This fifth Indiana Jones film has been in
development for a long time. Even all the
way back in the 1970s, George Lucas and
Steven Spielberg hoped to tell a quintet
of stories about the globe-trotting
adventurer. And after having waited
so long after The Last Crusade to make
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull, it didn't
seem like another big-screen outing could ever
happen. But following Crystal Skull's release,
Lucas began researching possible story
ideas. As he told the Times Online in 2008,
"I'm in the future; Steven's in the past. He's
trying to drag it back to the way they were,
I'm trying to push it to a whole different
place. So, still we have a sort of tension."
The project was stuck in development for
years before Lucas sold Lucasfilm to Disney,
who hoped to revive the series without him. At
that point, Spielberg and Crystal Skull writer
David Koepp began working on the script for
what would eventually become Dial of Destiny.
By 2018, Spielberg was preoccupied with other
projects, and Koepp was replaced by Solo writer
Jonathan Kasdan, son of Raiders of the Lost Ark
scribe Lawrence Kasdan, before returning quickly
thereafter. Eventually, Spielberg's version of
Indiana Jones 5 failed because he, Harrison Ford,
and Disney couldn't all agree on the script.
When James Mangold took the helm, things
seemed to be back on track. He rewrote Koepp's
script alongside his Ford v Ferrari writers,
brothers Jez and John-Henry Butterworth, with all
four men receiving final "written by" credits.
Following the sale of Lucasfilm, George
Lucas distanced himself from both Star Wars
and Indiana Jones. After Disney declined to use
his treatments for the Star Wars sequel trilogy,
his involvement in the space opera franchise
has been essentially nonexistent. Besides
visiting the set of The Mandalorian, he's
effectively bid his former glories goodbye.
While Lucas wrote and directed Star
Wars during his time as a filmmaker,
he was never actually a credited screenwriter for
any Indiana Jones movie. Instead, he helped craft
the story for each film, served as a producer,
and worked closely with Spielberg to make sure
that their shared vision became a reality.
But while Lucas' involvement in the fifth
Indiana Jones has been diminished following
his sale to Disney, he's still in the loop.
According to James Mangold, both Spielberg
and Lucas are involved with Dial of Destiny.
While they may not be in the director's
chair or receiving any story credit,
these two filmmaking giants just had to be
included in another Indiana Jones picture,
especially if it's going to be the final
one. Serving as executive producers,
Spielberg and Lucas have continued to help curate
Hollywood's most famous archeologist from afar,
which is surely comforting to plenty of loyal
fans. If they trust Mangold to deliver a killer
version of Indiana Jones, then the rest
of us probably shouldn't be too worried.
Since he directed the first four Indiana Jones
movies, one can't help but wonder how Steven
Spielberg feels about Dial of Destiny. He's been
the primary creator of the character for decades,
so an Indiana Jones movie without him
is sort of impossible to even imagine.
"Oh, dear."
Of course, the filmmaker is still involved and
serves as an executive producer alongside George
Lucas, but he isn't working as closely as he used
to this time around. But regardless of his time,
or lack thereof, on set, Spielberg is still
the authority on all things Indiana Jones,
which makes his thoughts on Dial
of Destiny all the more exciting.
After watching the film at a Disney
executive screening, he told Variety,
"When the lights came up I just turned to
the group and said, 'Damn! I thought I was
the only one who knew how to make one of these
[...] Everybody loved the movie. It's really,
really a good Indiana Jones film. I'm really
proud of what [Mangold] has done with it."
That's high praise coming from the man
who single handedly directed all of this
character's previous on-screen adventures. With
Spielberg clearly on board with this version,
our hopes for Dial of Destiny have only risen,
giving this installment the potential for
this to be one of the best of the series.
With Indy's favorite Egyptian excavator
Sallah returning for Dial of Destiny,
many have wondered if other fan
favorites could return as well.
Among the most requested is Ke Huy Quan's
Short Round from 1984's Temple of Doom.
"Okee-dokee, Dr. Jones. Hold on to your potatoes!"
Before recently, Quan was best known for his
work as Short Round and as Data in The Goonies,
which was released the following year. But
then in 2022, he returned to international
stardom thanks to the success of the multiversal
action-comedy-drama Everything Everywhere All at
Once. He played Waymond Wang, which earned
him an Academy Award for Best Supporting
Actor. After years away from the big screen,
Quan is suddenly doing quite well for himself.
In 2022, Quan and Harrison Ford shared a tearful
reunion at Disney's D23 convention, but alas, Quan
has insisted that he isn't returning for Dial of
Destiny. He told Entertainment Tonight in April,
"I want to say [I'll be in it], but no. Here's the
thing. I don't want to disappoint the fans. I've
joked about it all the time, but reuniting with
Harrison after 38 years, that was very special."
With this being Ford's final adventure as Indy,
and Quan unlikely to return as Short Round for
a potential spinoff, it seems like fans will
just have to settle for the off-screen reunion.
As Indy's original love interest, Karen Allen's
Marion Ravenwood is the only recurring female
character in the Indiana Jones chronology.
First appearing in Raiders of the Lost Ark,
she and Dr. Jones share a steamy
romantic history. Upon reuniting,
they resume their previous
affairs, at least for a while.
Since Temple of Doom took place a year
before the events of Raiders and The Last
Crusade focused mainly on Indy's relationship
with his father, Marion wasn't in either of
the first two sequels. But then Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull came along, with Allen appearing
with their son and managing to finally put a
ring on the elderly archaeologist's finger.
When Spielberg and Lucas first began
developing the fifth Indiana Jones film,
Allen initially expressed interest in returning
as Marion once more. As she told MovieWeb in 2011,
"I mean, we're married now, so it would be
difficult, I think, to move forward without her."
But ever since, there's been no official comment
regarding Allen's inclusion in Dial of Destiny.
Though James Mangold has confirmed that we'll
learn more about what happened to her and
Indy's son Mutt, we've heard nothing more about
her own status. With Allen seemingly radio silent,
we can only speculate about whether or not
she'll show up in the final chapter after all.
"Do you and Harrison talk?
Do you stay in contact?"
"We talk every now and then."
For nearly 30 years, the Indiana Jones series was
distributed by the motion picture giant Paramount
Pictures after Spielberg and Lucas made a deal for
five Indiana Jones pictures with the distributor.
The studio's famous mountain logo has appeared
at the beginning of each Indy flick, from 1981's
Raiders of the Lost Ark all the way to 2008's
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull. It's now pretty
much synonymous with Harrison Ford's globetrotting
adventures. Alas, nothing in Hollywood lasts
forever. So after Lucasfilm was sold to the Walt
Disney Company in 2012, Paramount's involvement in
any future Indiana Jones installments was subject
to change, and that change has in fact happened.
Paramount has retained its initial distribution
rights for the first four films in the series,
which is why they're currently
available on Paramount+ and not
Disney+. But the House of Mouse now owns
distribution rights to any future films.
Dial of Destiny is a co-production between
Lucasfilm and Disney, making it the first Indiana
Jones film not solely produced by Lucasfilm. But
Paramount has received an "associate credit" on
this latest picture, with an undisclosed financial
participation as well. How this all works behind
the scenes is a bit of a mystery, but it's
clear that the cooperation between Disney
and Paramount has only helped Indiana Jones going
forward. Still, replacing the snow-capped mountain
with the Disneyland castle will surely be
pretty hard for moviegoers to adjust to.
Unlike a lot of other action films, the
Indiana Jones series wasn't released in
strict chronological order. While Dial of
Destiny is the final feature in the saga,
parts of it fit between some of
Indy's other earlier adventures.
The first film chronologically in
the Indy timeline is Temple of Doom,
which takes place in 1935. Only a year later,
the events of Raiders of the Lost Ark unfold,
which see Indy and Marion fight a group of Nazis
in search of the Old Testament relic known as
the Ark of the Covenant. The Last Crusade
takes place a few years after that in 1939,
but not before a flashback to Indy's time as
a young man played by River Phoenix set in
1912. This is as far back in the past that
the feature films have ventured thus far.
"This should be in a museum."
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull was released
in 2008, but it takes place in 1957 during
the Cold War. A somewhat older Indy finds
his long-lost son Mutt, marries Marion,
and discovers the existence of extraterrestrial,
or rather interdimensional, creatures. As for Dial
of Destiny, though there will be flashbacks
to 1944, it will reportedly mostly be set in
1969. Thus, it will be the farthest forward
Indy has ever ventured in the 20th century.
Described by director James Mangold as "a
hero at sunset," Indy's fifth and final
big-screen adventure is set to be his swan
song. And while that's sad on some level,
there's plenty of mystery and excitement
with such a promise. Mangold is possibly
best known for directing the final two
installments of Fox's Wolverine trilogy,
so he's no stranger to telling
an action hero's final tale.
2017's Logan closed the book on Hugh Jackman's
long-running turn as the iconic X-Man,
at least until Marvel Studios introduced
the idea of him returning again. That film
pretty much told the definitive
Wolverine story for a generation,
so fans are anxious to see if Dial of
Destiny will employ the same tone and
effectively serve as Indy's version of Logan. As
Mangold rhetorically asked Entertainment Weekly,
"What does the hero do when the world no longer
has a place for him? I find it really interesting
to try to look at classical heroes through the
prism of our jaundiced contemporary attitudes."
"The best version of this movie was the one that
didn't do everything like all the other movies."
Mangold also compared Dial of Destiny
to Logan, while reassuring fans that
the film's tone would remain faithful to
the Indian Jones mythos. He further noted,
"I am under no illusions that my job making
an Indiana Jones film was to suddenly beat
the humor out of it and turn it into some
kind of dirge. I think that what we're
trying to do is balance both an accurate and
realistic appraisal of where this character
would be at this time in his life, and do that
honestly [...] This is an Indiana Jones film."
After Disney bought Lucasfilm in 2012,
fans wondered how the House of Mouse would
continue the Indiana Jones franchise. While
Star Wars has been Disney's main LucasFilm
priority following the sale, projects
like Dial of Destiny and the Disney+
series Willow prove that there's more to
Lucasfilm's catalog than just Star Wars.
After Dial of Destiny was greenlit and it
was announced that this would be Harrison
Ford's last outing, many speculated that Disney
would attempt to reboot the franchise through a
series of prequels. And for a while,
that looked like a real possibility.
In 2022, Variety reported that a prequel
series set before the events of Raiders
of the Lost Ark and probably Temple of Doom
was in the works at Disney+. But by 2023,
other sources implied that the series,
which would've been the first Indy
prequel since The Young Indiana Jones
Chronicles, had been scrapped entirely.
Then in April, ScreenRant reported that Dial of
Destiny would close out the franchise for good.
While this news sounds pretty final, recent
years have proven that nothing is permanent
in Hollywood. And while we shouldn't expect
a reboot any time soon, it would actually be
surprising if Disney and Lucasfilm never returned
to the world of Indiana Jones ever again.